nous recevons maintenant louis malle
pour son film au revoir les enfants
un film que vous pourrez voir sur vos
grands écrans à partir de demain
mercredi comme je dis à chaque fois
premières séances 14h la france là et
bien je vous résume en gros à l'histoire
je sais que les metteurs en scène même
pas s'abaisser pour situer l'intrigué
alors sachez que louis malle s'est
inspiré du souvenir ils ont le plus
dramatique qui nous confirmera tout à
l'heure de son enfant ça se passe en
1944 il avait 11 ans était pensionnaire
dans un collège catholique près de
fontainebleau
un de ses camarades de classe l'intrigué
beaucoup à l'époque il était dirons-nous
différend était secret et puis à ma
tasse tout ce petit monde s'est écroulé
son camarade est arrêté il vous
racontera un peu plus tard de quoi il
s'agit je vous propose de regarder
quelques images qui qui résume un peu ce
film
vous vous entendez bien avec votre
nouveau camarade monnaie soyez très
gentil avec lui
vous avez une influence sur les autres
je compte sur vous pourquoi il est
malade
maria n'a pas l'accent vous tenez si je
te disais tu serais pas aussi les coups
même temps que tu l'as pas vu mon père
ça c'est parce que les ans est amer
salé ou ta mère tu vas me dire voilà m
eur puis les gentils ton ami et parle
pas beaucoup
bien ces raisons j'ai peur tout le temps
mais mal comment peut-on garder je
dirais aussi longtemps en soi quelque
part enfouis dans son coeur un moment
aussi pénible qu'on a que vous avez
aussi souvent envie de mettre sur le
papier ou sur l'écran comme on fait pour
le garder
ou c'est d'abord c'est pas comme une
espèce d'objet étrangers quand là au
fond de l'estomac et qu'il faut un jour
extraits ça ça bouge tout le temps ça a
évolué dans les premières années après
ce qui m'est arrivé au fond ça provoque
et toutes sortes de réactions samassa
m'a beaucoup changé personnellement
comment ça ça vous a choisi parce que si
vous voulez d'avoir assisté à quelque
chose qui était si violent si brutale si
barbare et samassa massa m'a vraiment
des phases et sa cible et pour un enfant
de onze ans qui jusque là était très
protégé malgré les duretés de la guerre
on était quand même dans ce collège
derrière des murs et puis on a vu entrer
la violence le racisme tout compris
qu'entre cet enfant a été un des
week-ends on savait où la wii on l'avait
compris l'essentiel on avait compris que
lui c'est les deux autres qui était avec
lui était un danger de mort on sait pas
exactement ce qui allait lui arriver on
espérait que le revoir mais on savait
qu'il était en place et est quand même
l'époque c'était quand même
avez-vous ce qui est arrivé à ce petit
garçon qu'elle était son chemin depuis
le moment vous l'avez quittée je sais
très exactement ce qui lui est arrivé
parce qu'on l'a su du reste assez
longtemps après c'est à dire que il est
il est mort dans un camp de
concentration est assez vite après son
arrestation
alors c'est un film que vous avez
réalisé avec un certain nombre de jeunes
acteurs que nous allons voir
on dit toujours que c'est difficile de
les choisir que c'est assez difficile de
les faire travailler
mais vous aviez un nouveau camarade
françois truffaut qui avez prouvé que
vous pouvez faire de très belles choses
avec de jeunes enfants est-ce que c'est
toujours vrai c'est difficile de les
choisir de les faire travailler
non moi je trouve pas que c'est plutôt
plus facile que de travailler avec je
sais pas certaines vedettes de cinéma
que je ne nommerai pas mais en fait
c'est un grand plaisir pour moi je les
fais souvent et 7
c'est merveilleux d'abord d'avoir
affaire à des enfants est d'essayer de
les comprendre
c'est très difficile de les choisir
parce qu'à un moment donné on en voit
énormément il faut dire c'est celui là
je vais prendre pour jouer ce rôle c'est
une responsabilité énorme et c'est un
choix c'est un long retour si vous
voulez parce que tout de suite
on sait que si on s'est trompé c'est la
catastrophe moi ce film si je n'avais
pas trouvé
et évidemment travailler avec eux m'a
fait confiance à des enfants qui
personnellement je trouve ont été
merveilleux dans le film ce film
n'aurait pas fonctionnel cauneille la
pression que ce film aussi les va
quelque part changer eux aussi ont bien
sûr sachant que vous avez l'horreur
qu'ont là quand on fait des films avec
des enfants c'est que pendant les trois
mois du tournage ils changent tellement
qu'à la fin ils n'accordent plus et ça a
l'air d'une blague mais c'est vrai parce
que si vous laissez trois mois on leur
demande une concentration et ne peut
être une maturité exceptionnelle on les
force à vivre dans un espèce de
microcosme d'adultes
l'échangé chance physiquement parce
qu'ils changent mentalement mais eux
bien sûr c'est la changer mais comme ce
sont des enfants tout à fait
exceptionnelle ils sont retournés dans
leur lycée tout va bien alors je ne veux
pas ajouter mais je pourrais le faire au
concert de louanges que
deux de mes confrères de la presse
écrite une seule chose allez donc voir
ce film c'est demain sur les grands
écrans il faut aller au cinéma là où
c'est fait pour si j'ose dire si les
grandes salles de cinéma et ça s'appelle
au revoir les enfants au revoir monsieur
mal vous partez aux états unis vous
voulez le voir un jour je reste un petit
peu je reste vous restez ici c'est quand
même chez vous aussi l'affront
absolument la météo
laurent avec des images qui nous
viennent du midi qui sont pas très
agréables
effectivement des images d'inondations
qui